[Musique]
certaines personnes ont beaucoup de
peine sans vraiment triste de ce qui
m'est arrivé
des fois j'ai envie de pleurer mais je
me retiens des voix si choqué je pensais
pas qu'autant de gens s'intéresserait
aussi de faire partout dans le monde des
millions tout le monde parle de making
murderer et de la fère steven avery ce
n'est pas fini
quand quelqu'un est condamné il doit
remuer ciel et terre pour sortir de
prison
notre tâche à présent c'est d'obtenir
gain de cause par le biais d'un système
conçu pour donner l'avantagé aux
procureurs est ce qu'on a envie que la
bonne personne soit condamné oui
sûrement mais c'est secondaire par
rapport au reste
elle est partie et ça on ne pourra
jamais rien n'est changé la célèbre
avocate catherine waldner spécialiste
des condamnations injustifiées a repris
l'affairé habré mon objectif est de
faire annuler la condamnation de steven
avery pourquoi un homme avour est il un
crime qu'il n'a pas commis
il voulait des aveux à tout prix ils les
ont pu grâce à la pire des méthodes
s'est dit si je le redis ce qu'ils
veulent entendre
[Musique]
je pourrais rentrer à la maison
selon l'accusation teresa n'a jamais
quitté la propriété d avril or son
dernier appel a été captée par une
antenne relais se trouvant à des
kilomètres de la propriété
dans 70 à 80% des cas la victime est
assassiné par quelqu'un qu'elle connaît
tous les gens doivent être considérés
comme des suspects potentiels
si beaucoup de choses reposent sur cette
balle c'est un point crucial il y à tout
un tas d'un 10 une seule preuve pourrait
remettre en question tout le faire
la condamnation de dassier est annulé et
qu'un second procès commence
l'accusation raté d'une chance sans ses
amis bien compter de manitowoc ne s'en
remettra jamais barreaux ils ont soit
une famille heureuse comme avant je dois
essayer de restaurer notre bonheur je
bâtirai une grande maison ouvrira tous
et je m'occuperai d'eux je veux les
rendre heureux jusqu'à la fin de leur
vie c'est ça qui me fait peur
si les preuves contre avery son solide
s'il est bien coupable
alors j'ai jouerai